ne tout de suite avec éric pineault qui
est professeur à l'institut des sciences
de l'environnement de l'uqam bonsoir
bonsoir alors le chancelier allemand qui
est en mission énergétique qu'est ce
qu'il y a selon vous un véritable
potentiel pour les manques de de trouver
ici au canada l'énergie dont l'allemagne
a besoin
mais ça dépend de quelle énergie dont on
parle en termes d'énergie un petit gars
de renouvelables dont un gars gaz
naturel s'cusez moi n'ont pas vraiment à
court terme le canadien est pas en
mesure de livrer vers l'allemagne gnl
gaz naturel liquéfié
l'allemagne positionnant recevoir des
livraisons des états unis savaient de ce
côté là que les livraisons vont se faire
au plus rapide on pourrait commencer à
livrer du gaz naturel qui fuit dans cinq
à sept ans et le contexte va être
complètement différent je doute qu'on
ait encore un confidences enquête et a
plus qu'annulé russie donc c'est pas
vraiment de ce côté là scotty
l'hydrogène encore lol on est loin de la
coupe aux lèvres on n'est pas en mesure
de produire massivement des volumes
importants l'hydrogène il faut se
rappeler hydrogène ne s'est pas de
l'énergie c'est une manière de
transporter de l'énergie et converti six
de l'électricité en hydrogène verts on
en perd beaucoup du deux tiers à la
moitié tout dépend de la technologie
qu'on utilise alors ce qui est à faire
je crois c'est à développer c'est ce que
l'allemagne doit chercher dans ce moment
a développé une expertise sur comment
produire au plus bas coûts énergétiques
possibles de l'île de l'hydrogène qu'on
va transporter sous la forme d'ammoniac
j'imagine ça va être beaucoup plus la
manière que l'hydrogène qui vont faire
l'objet d'un transfert en bateau sur
toute la planète terre capable de
déplacer l'hydrogène en ce moment donc
même en terme même si on en produisait
yoko la flotte de navires capables de
déplacer cette ressource
mais par exemple éric pineault si on
allait de l'avant avec le projet en
nouvelle écosse par ci un projet de
terminal les qu'une entreprise c'est un
repsol est ce que ça ce serait possible
à partir de là de dire qu'on exporte de
l'hydrogène aussi du gaz naturel
liquéfié conviendrait exporter à partir
de la rue paul si le gaz naturel
liquéfié gnl aux primes gnl c'est aussi
qu' on ne pourra avoir un terminal en
nouvelle écosse mais on ne passe pas mal
de tuyaux entre la nouvelle-écosse et
les gisements en alberta en
colombie-britannique on n'a pas la
capacité pour transporter le gaz naturel
canadien
repsol ou goldboro d'autres faux 10 ans
us pourrait s'approvisionner dans les
appalaches donc ce serait du gaz naturel
américain mais je vois pas l'intérêt des
américains dans wheeler gaz au canada
pour l'envoyer par la suite en europe
alors on a le problème du tuyau et on a
le problème d'installer des facilités
l'idée qu'on pourrait installer une
usine de gnl et vend seulement la
convertir en production d'hydrogène qui
était un peu miroiter la semaine passée
par un gouverneur fédéral non ce que la
technique le sous poil chimiques et
physiques c'est pas possible c'est pas
rien pourquoi
mais simplement parce que c'est des
facilités complètement différente et les
technologies complètement différente
concret à moins qu'on a moins qu'on
veuille faire de l'hydrogène dit ploeren
ça ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'on
fait de l'hydrogène guy mauffette
l'hydrogène avec du gaz naturel et après
autant de capturer le co2 et entendent
eux donc de neutraliser citerne à
l'impact climatique donateurs hydrogène
les technologies pour pour faire ce type
de développement sont pas matures on
n'arrive pas à capturer assez de co2
pour que ce soit vraiment rentable ce
plan climatique donc pour le moment
l'hydrogène d'ibm ce n'est pas une voie
d'avenir l'hydrogène va être je peins
énergétique si ce qui est a développé
par contre exactement c'est à développer
mais ça demeure complexe comme vous
l'exprimez bien you lie l'hydrogène gris
qu'on produit déjà donc à partir
d'énergies fossiles et le gaz naturel
touron c'en était déjà parlé dans le
passé de l'ouest canadien puis de la
formation de maintenir sur lequel le
canada compte beaucoup quand même qu'ils
passent en colombie-britannique qui
passe en alberta cette formation-là peut
générer beaucoup de gaz naturel est ce
qu'on pourrait dire qu'on exporte vers
l'europe mais en passant par le
pacifique la terre est ronde quand même
on pourrait passer par un canal + plus
long mais en fait le marché du gnl de
machines et équipements qui régionaliser
quand même l'asie l'europe mais un
potentiel veut des prix sont de plus en
plus convergent vers un prix mondial
une fois qu'ils rendu sono effectivement
le coup et déjà - il y aurait cette
possibilité de transporter par voie
maritime le canadien effectivement fait
face à une contrainte d'exportation que
juste utilisé la moitié du gaz qu'on a
et donc si on veut développer la
ressource et bien on doit trouver une
l'exporter pour le moment si on regarde
du côté des transporteurs canadien
transcanada un bridge les transporteurs
canadiens mise beaucoup sur deux lieux
le golfe du mexique et la côte ouest
c'est les vieux sur lesquels ces
transporteurs à la mise pour certains la
gazette du canada on parle pas du reste
du canada si vous allez regarder les
communications de tracer
transcanadien on parle vraiment pas la
côte est donc dans ce contexte là
d'instabilité économique et énergétique
avec la guerre en ukraine pile canada
qui veut prendre qui veut prendre de
toute évidence une certaine
responsabilité pour fournir de l'énergie
est ce qu'il faudrait repenser réanimer
gnl québec non je pense pas qu'on ait on
est je pense pas que c'est selon les
allemands ont besoin je pense que les
amours une capable d'aller chercher
s'ils le veulent le gaz naturel liquéfié
plutôt du côté du moyen-orient du côté
des états unis nous ce qu'on pourrait
contribuer je pense s'est développé avec
eux la filiale de l'hydrogène pourquoi
les allemands besoins des drivers c'est
parce que c'est un une substance comme
besoin dans des procédés industriels là
où il n'y a pas de substitution possible
l'hydrogène valls est une ressource très
très très précieuse il faut l'utiliser
vraiment au meilleur usage c'est pas
pour les automobiles c'est bon pour les
camions c'est vraiment mais vise usage
critique et l'allemagne en a besoin
c'est un producteur industriel important
et donc là je pense qu'on est vraiment
une contribution à faire via un
partenariat qui peut être solide je
pense pas que quelques gnl sa partie de
l'équation est bon on a racheté le gnl
pour d'autres raisons s'il ya des
raisons de biodiversité que des raisons
des raisons pour en termes de
contribution au changement climatique ou
si le et donc je pense pas que gnl
québec par contre si le québec veut
explorer la possibilité de développer
l'hydrogène vers être avec les allemands
pour le faire oui mais il ya un espèce
de loi dans des engins vers le meilleur
usage qu'on peut faire d'une molécules
d'hydrogène sécher soit le plus con
transport le plus con à des pertes et
donc il ya un intérêt aussi peut-être
côté légèrement développer la recherche
et développement a développé une
expertise dans l'éolien la conversion
d'énergie éolienne en allemagne est
requise idéalement pour l utiliser ces
mêmes approches l'eau dans l'argile
éolien qui est la mère d'ilan rila c'est
vraiment intéressant c'est complexe mais
c'est très intéressant est tellement
important sur le plan stratégique
économique énergétique mondiale merci
eric pinon d'avoir été avec nous ce soir
ou demain
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit